what are you hello and welcome to my
home to come in my name is Arturo do
close this is my home and it's also my
gallery where I exhibit my works of art
they look a great place to live and to
enjoy life ya toh aqua that's it for the
last 30 years I've used political
cultural and social symbols in my art
sociali load OPI since 1983 I've been
working with bones the amino acid
thought I started to use them as symbols
of the disappeared detainees and the
repression that went on during the
military dictatorship dato de hierro
lado de neo desaparecio
boom what they appoint me like this is a
photo of my wife Germany here Dominique
that's what we like we've lived here for
the last five years we live in downtown
Santiago my living room and the rest of
our flat is filled with our collections
some people have photo albums we tell
our life stories through the objects we
collected over him anymore mother we
have more than 900 pieces they come from
all over the place for example this one
comes from Colin others from Mexico like
these little ones you see here and these
are from Bolivia and they will neva keep
the loo got it you know what else we
love to cook and we invite people over
to share good food but me and so waiting
for me it's really important to grow my
own herbs I have lots of them out here
on my balcony here i have managed
another fresher africa bueno no
encontramos key we're here in the
historical district of santiago it
really isn't that old but it does show
the last 150 years of our history ena yo
ideally toria aqui lo ultimo ciento
cincuenta Y so now you've seen why this
is the perfect place for me to live
thank you so much for coming to see my
home and until next time bye box LOL